[Music]
this dancing laser display is a behavior
never seen before in
light it's called branched flow a
phenomenon where beam
splits along its path in theory it could
happen to any form of
wave under the right conditions here the
complex pattern is created with a
laser and a simple soap bubble and this
experiment is shedding new light
on the phenomenon a number of things can
happen when a wave
any wave travels through a medium
certain random variations in a medium
can cause the wave to spread
out others will keep the wave focused
as it travels but if the wave travels
through just the right kind of medium
you end up with
that's right branched flow the beam
divides up into an intricate
tree-like pattern for branched flow to
occur the medium's random structure must
be larger than the wave's wavelength
and has to vary smoothly in all
directions
researchers first spotted this wave
behavior in 2001 in
electrons which can behave like waves
scientists have also spotted branch flow
with microwaves
and have even seen hints of it in
tsunamis
but the phenomenon still hadn't been
recreated in visible light
until now a group of researchers shone a
laser beam along the curved film of a
soap bubble
to their surprise the light split into
filaments as it traveled
it turned out that variations in the
bubbles thickness were creating the
branched flow phenomenon
the team also investigated the branching
for flat bubble films
as the soapy surface fluctuates the
branching pattern
evolves shining a separate light on the
bubble film from above
reveals how thick the bubble is in
different places
and the team used this information to
investigate how properties of the
branching pattern
like the average position of the first
branch are affected by the bubble
these bubbly experiments aren't easy to
set up
getting the light to travel inside the
bubble film is particularly fiddly
and it's hard to study something when
your apparatus has a tendency to pop
but now that the team have shown how to
create this phenomenon with light
they expect other groups around the
world to investigate it too
the experiment could help physicists
understand the branch flow behavior
this could one day open the door to
applying it to certain tasks
such as probing the properties of
biological membranes
so there's still plenty to learn from
this tree
of light